lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
pensar acerca del por qué es tan difícil
para un competidor monopólico hacer
dinero a la larga y solo para recordar
un competidor monopólico está más
cercano a la competencia perfecta y
después es un monopolio lo cual
significa que tiene un monopolio y su
producto diferenciado pero eventualmente
otra gente va a ser productos sustitutos
de este pues no pueden hacer exactamente
tu producto no pueden hacerlo idéntico
pero podrán comerse un poco tu demanda y
para entender esto vamos a dibujar la
curva de la demanda para el mercado el
cual tiene una competencia monopólica y
lo dibuje lo suficientemente grande para
entenderlo y este eje de por aquí voy a
graficar lo que va a ser pesos por
unidad así que el precio va a depender
de los ingresos por unidad pues tenemos
costo por unidad y cosas por el estilo y
luego por acá vamos a hablar en términos
bastantes generales pero refiriéndonos a
la cantidad producida en un periodo de
tiempo
ahora vamos a suponer que nuestro
competidor monopólico en esta ocasión
hacer apple con las ipads las ipads de
apple y quiero enfatizar que no estoy
tratando de acusar que a posea un
monopolio sino que ellos simplemente
tienen un producto diferenciado y
entonces ellos serán un competidor
monopólico en ese aspecto ellos tendrán
un monopolio con sus ipads no tendrán un
monopolio de las tabletas o de
computadoras en general pero únicamente
ellos van a vender ipads y nuestra curva
de la demanda luce algo así entonces
esta es nuestra curva de la demanda
hablando en términos del mercado de
ipads no del mercado de tabletas u otras
cosas apple es el monopolio en el
mercado de ipads por lo que su ingreso
marginal tendrá dos veces la pendiente
en esta curva entonces va a lucir algo
así la curva de ingreso marginal de
apple va a hacer esto y luego piensa
acerca de su beneficio económico o
ganancia económica a corto plazo en un
periodo de tiempo dado donde sea cuál
sea la cantidad va a lucir de la
siguiente forma entonces
dibujemos dichos costos donde primero
voy a dibujar el costo marginal y
entonces el costo marginal deberá lucir
algo así
y luego vamos a tener el costo promedio
total porque aquí es cuando tienes una
cantidad muy baja la mayor parte de tus
costos son costos fijos pero lo estarás
dividiendo en pequeñas cantidades por lo
que vas a tener un muy alto promedio
total de costos un alto a una alta media
de costos totales pero se va a ir
disminuyendo y disminuyendo tanto como
el costo en dicho incremento de unidad
sea inferior a la media y el costo en
dicho incremento de unidad es la curva
del costo marginal siempre y cuando el
costo total medio o promedio sea más
alto que la curva de costo marginal y
ahora ese incremento de unidad que
agregas te va a incrementar el promedio
o la media pues ese incremento de
unidades son más que el promedio y
entonces hace que el promedio suba y de
hecho por aquí vamos a tener un punto
mínimo en esta curva del costo total
medio así que dada la forma en como
dibuje las cosas cuál es el beneficio
económico o ganancia a corto plazo de
apple
bien pues tenemos que pensar en su
cantidad óptima a producir y
definitivamente va a producir una
cantidad donde su ingreso marginal sea
mucho más elevado que el costo marginal
y se obtengan beneficios económicos con
dicha unidad producida que se seguirá
produciendo más adelante y haciendo esto
hasta el final hasta cierto punto de
aquí y no se querrá producir más que eso
pues aquí tienes un buen costo de
oportunidad que te va a generar ingresos
y si no tendrías una pérdida económica
entonces por aquí vamos a tener dicha
cantidad en esta línea de aquí luego
tenemos esta parte de abajo que pusimos
con una estrellita y entonces esta
altura de aquí sería el precio que puede
cobrarse en el mercado o el precio
promedio en el que puedes tener ingresos
por unidad y luego tendríamos nuestro
costo promedio por unidad por acá por lo
que este costo promedio nos daría una
media de la ganancia económica por
unidad y si multiplicamos eso por el
número total de unidades si lo
multiplicamos por el número total
esta área de rectángulo de aquí nos va a
dar la ganancia económica total la
ganancia económica total como lo puse
por acá y como tú sabes la gente gusta
costos de oportunidad o lo que les
conviene en el mercado y entonces otros
competidores dirían bueno nosotros no
podemos producir ipads pero podemos
hacer productos bastante competitivos y
aquí por eso nace samsung htc hp u otras
marcas que se hacen como manualmente
como microsoft o google con android y
entonces estas marcas le generan
competencia a las ipads con sus tabletas
y entonces éstas manejan demasiado
marketing en sus productos y tratan de
hacer productos lo mejor
agresivos posibles y dichos productos se
vuelven más y más comparables con las
ipads o incluso hasta mejores en ciertas
dimensiones con los precios o algunas
otras características haciendo su
mercado bastante bueno y con bastante
mercadotecnia y así vamos a la curva de
demanda de apple que pasaría a largo
plazo con esto
a cualquier precio menor que este será
muy demandado y la curva de demanda se
desplazará hacia abajo la curva de
demanda se desplazará hacia la izquierda
y entonces podríamos terminar con una
nueva curva demanda y la voy a poner con
un diferente color que va a ser azul por
aquí y luce algo así entonces esta sería
nuestra nueva curva de demanda o tal vez
deberíamos decir que nuestra nueva curva
de demanda a largo plazo después de que
estas personas ya hayan hecho sus
productos mucho mejores y hayan hecho
muchísima mercadotecnia y si tenemos una
nueva curva de demanda entonces qué va a
pasar con nuestro ingreso marginal a
largo plazo el cual antes era con dos
pendientes negativas ahora va a lucir
algo así y creo que estoy utilizándolo
con el mismo color entonces voy a
utilizar otro color que sea el rosa y
esta sería nuestra curva de ingreso
marginal y va a lucir algo así entonces
esto que tenemos de aquí nuestro nuevo
ingreso marginal que nos dará ahora de
nueva cantidad óptima para él
bueno pues ahora nuestra ganancia
económica va a ir por todo este camino
hasta este punto de aquí y entonces
tenemos nuestra nueva producción a largo
plazo y creo que debería hacerlo de
diferente color estoy usando demasiado
rosa pero bueno la cantidad de producir
a largo plazo va a estar por aquí y para
figurar nos los ingresos por unidad o el
precio de la de la cantidad simplemente
subimos la curva de demanda nuestra
nueva curva de demanda pues recuerda que
es a largo plazo y estando sobre esta es
el precio no cambiará mucho así que
tenemos el mismo precio pero ahora cuál
es nuestra ganancia económica promedio
por unidad bien lo que dibuje es el
promedio de costos totales por aquí y
está súper cerca de los precios entonces
nuestro promedio de ganancias económicos
por unidad va a bajar a cero pues como
puedes ver después de esta altura verde
ya no teníamos más altura y entonces
incluso pensando que estamos vendiendo
un buen número de unidades nuestro
promedio económico de ganancias por
unidad
por lo que de ganancia económica
tendremos cero y algo importante a
enfatizar en un monopolio competitivo es
que esto no pasará de la noche a la
mañana pues podemos decir que esto es en
el 2012 a inicios de 2012 12 donde apple
está generando inmensidad de cantidades
de ganancias pues ahora como las
personas saben es que apple está
generando demasiadas ganancias incluso
muchísimo más allá del costo de
oportunidad pero es un trabajo que se
llevó en curso durante todo el 2012 y
apenas la curva de la demanda se está
yendo hacia la izquierda debido a toda
la competencia que se ha desatado
agresivamente así que lo importante aquí
es darse cuenta que los competidores
monopólicos seguramente tengan curvas
que luzcan como monopolios pero que la
competencia no deja que pasen en
términos de suministros de ipads pues
ninguno de estos competidores pueden
suplirlos sin embargo haciendo una gran
competencia para las ganancias que esta
empresa pueda tener